pour vous qui aimez vivre dangereusement
voici enfin des chaussures vraiment
dangereuse les chaussures suspense avec
les chaussures suspense votre vie est
une suite de folles aventures
quelle merveilleuse suspense le moindre
déplacement la moindre course en ville
de vienne de palpitantes d'escapades et
les escaliers sont pour vous des
cantiques terrain de dérapage essayez
les chaussures suspense et pour celles
qui ont vraiment le goût du risque
voici un conseil en choisissant vos
chaussures suspense un peu grande vous
doublerez vos sensations en bénéficiant
d'un déséquilibre horizon pape
allez-y rosie vraiment grâce aux
chaussures suspense pour quelques
dizaines de francs c'est tout un monde
aventure qui entrent dans votre vie par
les pieds